foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
if if I would have told you 24 hours ago
the final score of the Bucks Panthers
would be 21-3
what would you have said Rick
I just said the Bucks won but they they
didn't play very well but they're just
happy they won I mean nobody saw this
coming Dance I mean you know I'm
starting to feel like Tom Brady's Jim
Cantore you call me anytime there's a
storm brewing and you know and I'm
standing on the doorstep of a crisis and
and yeah it's just weird man you know
they're just not a very good football
team and this is what I've come to
realize is that you know we know the
players are missing whether it's Gronk
or the guys they've all their free
agents are injured Tom's playing okay
um but their defense now is is a sieve
when it doesn't need to be and I mean
look at who they've lost to these last
two weeks I don't know that you could
find a team they could beat right now
and that's that's the worst thing you
can say
well when you have a coach saying you
know I don't know if it can get any
darker well it can you have Baltimore
Thursday night yeah
right good luck with Lamar Jackson I
think he's going to score more than 20.
I could be wrong but yeah it is going to
get darker and this is the thing I mean
you know there's already uh columns
being written about you know should they
fire Byron Leftwich and you know what if
Bruce Arians called the plays and you
know and that's that's not going to
happen I mean I I don't think you know
Bruce Arians would be coaching this team
I believe if Tom Brady wanted him to and
you know that's that's sort of not the
case and so they're gonna have to figure
this out and yet you know if Mike Evans
catches that passed in early in that
game I just feel like you know they have
a different feel about themselves and
sometimes it can just take one play
um to take kind of the pressure off of
everybody and say okay we're going to be
all right so it just hasn't happened yet
but they're still in the playoff mix
here it's it's not a formidable team the
way you know we've seen in the past but
you're in an easier division the NFC is
kind of watered down for the most part
so is that the hope you think that uh
Brady and the Buccaneers are selling
absolutely I mean you know they're three
and four they they're tied with Atlanta
but they've beaten the Atlanta Falcons
this could be one of those years I don't
know how many years ago it was the NFC
South was one at seven and nine of
course they got 17 games now but
um I don't know if it's going to go that
way it's just you look at you look at
what they're facing and you know they've
got to get themselves straightened out
and they got to do it fast I mean after
Baltimore you got to play the Rams you
got to go across over to Germany and
play a Seattle team that's playing
really well right now so like I said
it's it's really about them let's see
what they do at the trade deadline too
and I don't know how many guys are gonna
be you know stoked to come here but as
far as free agent goes you probably lost
Odell Beckham at this point but they
need to they need to be active in that
look this is this was all chips to the
table you know Brady's all in and and
they they went out and tried to you know
get as many free agents all those guys
are hurt for the most part and it's just
not nothing is working out right now but
it can change and you know you know the
guy I understand going to quit working
he's going to try to get it right so
there's still plenty of season left but
it is it is dark and gloomy as uh as
Todd bull said do you agree with Ben
Roethlisberger who said when he watched
Brady that he just didn't look like he
wanted to be out there
I think he wants to be out there
um he's having a a you know a lot of
Crisis off the field that I think we're
all sort of aware of and and I think
that's taken a lot of the joy out of
playing you know
um whatever he's going through
personally is is certainly sapping his
energy he's lost weight
[Music]
um you know he has not been for him
which is rare all as invested as he has
in the past taking time off you know in
training camp going to you know Bob
Craft's wedding all those things get
publicized when you don't win
um but but that's the reality and you
know players talk about that I think
people talk about it outside of the
building and it becomes a story but I I
think he's still the most prepared
quarterback in the NFL and I think he
will be
um and you know I don't think his
shoulder's all that great either Dan I
think he's playing you know with with
sort of a hurt Wing as well so who knows
what all is going on I'm not sure we
will for some time but but he's
certainly not the guy that was here in
2020 and you know that they need him to
be that guy
safe travels as always and uh well you
know stay by your phone just in case
they lose on Thursday night we'll
probably talk to you on Friday
all right I'm on the dock watching the
storm roll in man just give me a call
that's Rick Stroud Tampa Bay Times
what's the line on Thursday night with
the Ravens and the Buccaneers
as we mentioned that with the Packers
and the bills
do you want to play guess that line
guess that one Buccaneers hosting the
Ravens over under 45 I'm sorry 44 and a
half
say Buccaneers
by two and a half Buccaneers by one
well now after I've said by two and a
half it's going to go up
that's how much power I've got by one